hey everybody welcome back to one dream
now where we give you an inside look at
some of the series currently streaming
on one dream i'm rich burnett and in
today's show we'll be traveling the
ancient roman empire and learning how to
be an effective ancient roman orator so
put on your favorite toga and let's get
[Music]
started today's first guest is darius
arya darius is an archaeologist public
historian author and tv host based out
of rome but most recently you'll know
darius from his new series traveling the
ancient roman empire
let's take a peek
i'm archaeologist daria zarya and
together
we'll explore the expanse of the roman
empire over three continents
meeting oversized personalities seeing
incredible monuments in urbanization and
also how rome co-opted and organized the
provinces and their resources rome left
an indelible mark on diverse cultures
that we can still explore today for
insights into the impact and legacy of
the roman empire and how we can connect
to that rich past
it's an adventure
with endless new perspectives to
discover
darius hello thank you for joining us
hey great to be here
where are you today
uh right now i'm in rome and i'm at a
place called large argentina large
argentina is a place known for four
republican temples you can see some of
the columns behind me it's also the
place where julius caesar was meeting
with the uh roman senate and he was
assassinated on the ides of march so
there's a lot of history in this
archaeological site here that's wild so
why are you actually there right now
i actually i live in rome so this is
just uh my neighborhood this part of my
neighborhood walk so we actually have
you here to talk a little bit about your
new show with one dream which is called
traveling the ancient roman empire can
you tell us a little bit about it
well i don't want to give it all away
but uh
we will be doing a lot of traveling and
we'll be seeing some incredible sights
monuments cities on three continents so
i'm i'm really excited so i know in the
series you visit a lot of uh well-known
ancient cities and locations but what
are some of the lesser-known areas that
you explore
uh you know there are there are parts of
morocco
uh there are
little-known
uh sites within jordan so i mean you're
gonna know petra and you're going to
know amman the capital city which at one
point is an impressive roman city but
then there are so many other
fortifications temples sanctuaries and
then
just the the
landscape i think is going to give you
an
a really good sense of
how expansive the empire was and just
how challenging it was to hold that
empire together so we're going
everywhere the romans went so
it's the strip of north africa it's what
we call the middle east
up to turkey over to
greece and then the balkans and then all
of central europe
over to uh you know the uk to scotland
to england so this series is this
something that a viewer could use as a
as a sort of travel guide
oh absolutely i mean we're we're getting
in there deep we're we're going to the
experience of of being
in a certain sense you know the academic
tourists themselves but it's also about
experiencing the food and the
contemporary culture it's not just
parachuting into sight it's getting a
sense of the realities of those cities
today
um and and the food that goes along with
it and the vibrant culture that
surrounds it the local communities that
still embrace those ruins so i think
it's a it's a great opportunity that
gives you a sense of far-off lands and i
think they'll really they're going to
pull you in you're going to want to
visit them yourself
so why is this uh series important for
today's world for today's audience
well i think today you know we talk
about a globalized world and we talk
about the connectivity
of different cultures
and the romans achieved that already
right they had this incredible landmass
and it wasn't just military conquest
there were systems in place there was a
great economy there was trade travel was
facilitated so it really was a a really
important moment in history
but achieved 2 000 years ago so i think
we can see some very interesting
parallels and we can be in awe of that
the technology the infrastructure how it
all worked uh belief systems and there's
there's a you know a variety of beliefs
there's a lot
a variety of traditions so rome the
empire is not in a vacuum it's always
interacting with a larger world and
that's basically the world we live in
today
so we've been collecting questions from
our audience on social media as we like
to do when we interview our presenters
so i have a few questions here for you
to answer
uh we could start with bill m on
facebook who asks if i only had enough
time to visit one ancient roman site
which one would you recommend
i mean i'm biased i mean if it's a roman
site you only got one chance you've got
to come to rome uh so there's a lot to
see here if it were one monument i'd
even say
probably hit the pantheon
because it is just so spectacular and uh
and you don't have to imagine the way it
looked like we have the whole thing
uh so i'm a big i'm a big fan of rome of
course
i've got a follow-up to that um when you
go to visit rome these days is there a
time that's better than others to avoid
being packed in with a bunch of tourists
you know right now there really are no
tourists but generally speaking it's
just the normal flow of the year it's
going to be very dead in
january and february of course it's kind
of our cold and rainy months but to have
more of the sites museums and so forth
to yourself so you have a lot of
different you know times to come but
again it gets more rainy in november and
then colder in december so you have that
kind of
off season but whenever you come rain or
shine you're going to have an amazing
experience
sure
all right let's go to renee on twitter
who asks
what are your thoughts on modern
reconstruction techniques on ancient
sites does it ruin their historical
integrity
that's a great that's a great question
people have been re-erecting columns for
such a long time uh including in rome
and the uh in the 19th century and even
earlier but um you know there's a right
way to do it and there's a wrong way to
do it so there is a certain
academic procedure you don't want that
reconstruction to overwhelm your
experience so number one is there's got
to be that base amount of core material
that's there behind me here there are
some columns uh from a temple that dates
to 101 bce
they were not reconstructed they were
not re-erected they were simply embedded
into later medieval walls that by the
1920s they were dismantled and lo and
behold they were revealed so it's not
that every time you'll see
columns in an archaeological site they
were necessarily reconstructed but again
the reconstruction is something that if
it's measured and done properly is a
great benefit to the viewer
let's go to leanne on instagram who asks
what are some of the most obvious
influences of the ancient roman empire
on our modern world
oh boy well we can look at uh
architecture we can look at literature
uh poetry
we can look at different legal systems i
mean so many things are indebted uh to
the romans and of course if you're
looking at your capital cities of so
many countries in europe
they were first roman cities
uh
london and paris
and it's worth investigating learning
more about those people because in the
end it's really about the people it's
not just the material remains it's their
thoughts it's their ideas and we're so
fortunate that we have hundreds of
thousands of inscriptions of detailing
their lives so that level then of
connectivity and familiarity that allows
us
to explore and dig deeper and i think
really take away you know a lot of great
insights and information and just get
you really excited
about travel about the beauty of the
architecture
uh design and just that lasting impact
they've had on so many parts of north
africa the middle east and central
europe
darius thank you so much for joining us
today you have a fun and interesting
lifestyle i'm a little jealous where can
people find out more about you and the
work that you do well you can find me on
all the social media channels uh
instagram twitter facebook darius arya
diggs i'm happy to converse and share
i'm always posting a photo a video of
some museum with some archaeological
sites uh in rome and beyond and then uh
i direct a non-profit uh it's where i've
been excavating for many years and
teaching it's called the american
institute for roman culture and we have
a learning platform it's free free
information free videos and that's
called ancient rome live cool i'll put
links to those in the description of
this video it was a pleasure talking to
you take care all right thank you very
much i'd like to take a quick moment to
remind you that guests on the show are
experts from our family here at wandrum
in addition to series about ancient rome
you'll also find topics like science
mental health and even foreign language
instruction and personal development
there's something for everyone on one
dream
and now with the recent addition of
dozens of documentaries and how-to
series there's never been a better time
to join
if you want to binge watch something
watch something that's smart by experts
on biodiversity mayan history physics
art
streaming is a lot smarter with one
dream wondrous because i wonder
knowledge is now streaming at one dream
our next guest is here to talk with us a
bit more about ancient roman culture
greg aldrete earned his phd in ancient
historical studies
his published work ranges in scope from
the flooding of the tiber to how to
reconstruct and test ancient body armor
and to today's topic which is all about
ancient roman gestures
greg welcome
hi it's pleasure to be here
first off
i love your setting where are you at
right now uh i'm in my home office so
this is where i do all my research in my
writing
it's a it's a beautiful library you got
going on there so greg you're actually
in the process of writing your seventh
series with us now isn't that correct
yes that's correct uh this one's going
to be called unsung heroes of the
ancient world
and it will look at some of my favorite
men and women of antiquity ranging from
generals to inventors
queens to bandits uh all of whose
exploits are perhaps somewhat
underappreciated and maybe a bit
forgotten today
very cool i look forward to that one and
we're gonna have you back on when that
one's out but for today
there's a very specific area of ancient
roman culture
that you studied i actually
mentioned it in your intro
i'd love to talk more about it and this
is ancient roman gestures
how do you get into studying ancient
roman gestures
well a theme that has run all throughout
my scholarship over the last i guess
three three and a half decades is that
i'm always interested in practical
questions how did things actually work
in the ancient world
and way back in grad school i was
studying ancient rhetoric
and i kept reading these accounts of
famous orders like cicero who would give
speeches in front of
huge crowds of tens of thousands of
people
and i got to wondering
how exactly did that work in an era
before there was any artificial means of
voice amplification like microphones or
loudspeakers
and it turns out that part of the answer
is that roman orders employed a system
of sign language when they spoke
and this helped because it's possible to
see a gesture
at a farther distance than you can hear
a voice i find that fascinating
how do we have any kind of record
uh without videos
to capture
what these gestures looked like
yeah well that's exactly the relevant
question and it turns out i had two
sources of information
uh first of all several prominent roman
orders including cicero and especially
another guy named quintillion
wrote a number of oratorical handbooks
the problem with those handbooks though
is that their verbal descriptions of
gestures are quite often
honestly unclear or kind of confusing
and this is where my second type of
evidence came in and that is ancient art
in a whole variety of media ranging from
statues to coins we have visual
depictions
of roman
politicians actors and orders
making various hand and body gestures
very cool what are some of
this might sound like a silly question
but
what are some of your favorite examples
of gestures and the meanings behind them
uh well i'll give you a sort of the
example i always use with my students so
let me actually perform in latin and
using actual roman oratorical gestures
uh a famous opening line of one of
cicero's real speeches this is uh the
pro ligario and for this particular line
quintillion in his rhetorical handbook
quite hopefully identifies the exact
places where cicero would have
gesticulated so here we go
noam crema
guy e kaiser et
ante honk diem
non audito
propinques meus ad tay
quintus tubero
de tulit
now a kind of a rough translation of
that would be um
of a new crime gaius caesar and one that
before today had never been heard of my
relative quintus tubro has accused you
now how that ties back with gesture
is that unlike today's um modern sign
language
roman oratorical gestures did not mean
the same thing as the words
so for example when i pushed my hands to
the left
that's a roman oratorical gesture that
they thought conveyed the emotion of
aversion so you'd use that when you were
saying something that disgusted you or
you didn't like
uh when i slapped my thigh it meant
anger when i clenched my fist and
pressed against my chest it meant grief
uh one of my favorite gestures is the
one this hand one that goes like this
any ideas what that gesture might mean
in emotional terms if i were to guess to
me it looks like it's bo
it's counterintuitive because it's a
halt it's a don't come closer sign and
then a bit of an invitation so i i'm
curious i don't know yeah it's a funny
one uh and this actually to the romans
indicated wonder or amazement so you
kind of get a sense of that so some of
these seem very intrinsic like kind of
the fist against the chest everybody
would see his grief this one's a little
more artificial but if you've been
trained to sort of know that gesture
know what it meant it would probably
register as wonder amazement to you
think about how music is used in movies
today so if you're watching a horror
film they'll use sharp kind of strident
chords which make you feel tense or
nervous if it's a love story they'll use
strings to kind of soothe you and make
you feel romantic well cicero was very
well aware of this and he said that the
same way that certain musical tones can
make you feel
happy sad tense whatever certain
postures of the body or gestures will
make you feel certain emotions a
question here that
i'm wondering is how much did the
audience actually know
about these gestures that these master
orators were using
were they
well-versed in what these gestures meant
or were they just supposed to
feel
based off of the actions themselves
yeah that's a great question in fact
that's one of the big questions i had to
look into in my book and it looks like
there was a kind of vocabulary of
gesture that was known by a lot of
audiences and this came from two
directions one was that public speeches
were almost a form of entertainment in
ancient rome i mean there were people
who would just go hang out in the forum
to watch kind of the entertaining
orators talk to the crowds and also a
lot of roman law cases were not held in
um you know courtroom hidden away they
too were held out in the forum and
crowds would come and watch these things
in the late republic especially there
were a lot of what today would call
celebrity court trials where very famous
men were put on trial and everybody
would gather to watch these things and
the orators were very aware that they
had to play to the crowd uh that
interaction with the crowd was a huge
part of trying to win the court cases
and so the crowds would know this kind
of vocabulary of gesture and they would
know them not just from politics and the
law system but from entertainment as
well
how have gestures from
ancient rome evolved what do we still
see today are there any echoes today
that are still being used that were
developed you know during this this uh
period well the basic kind of
rules for effective public speaking are
are seemingly timeless i mean the same
sorts of things that cicero advocates
which were very successful in antiquity
you can see are what we tend to point to
in orders today where we consider very
effective orders and this is down to
very specific things i mean there's all
this stuff about you know you should
gesture between the level of your eyes
your waist your right hand should be the
dominant hand of gesture the left should
mimic the right uh there's all these
sort of very technical things but if we
even just think about uh delivery which
is uh the whole how you give a speech um
everybody probably knows from personal
experience or school with teachers that
you could have a very mediocre speech in
terms of content but if it's given in an
inspired exciting way you're pretty
entertained and enjoy that and you pay
attention whereas on the other hand you
might have a brilliantly written speech
but if the delivery is dull and boring
it's just not effective
and it's also true that the
practitioners of outstanding delivery
and maybe this is an unfortunate aspect
of public speaking is that it's possible
to use those sorts of skills for very
different moral purposes and we see this
with a lot of
sort of people regarded as famous
orators from the last let's say 100
years
so if we looked at two figures like um
martin luther king and hitler
both of them were highly effective
orators
both of them used a lot of gestures when
they spoke and both were absolute
masters of arousing their audience's
emotions so it's back to that core
concept of cicero but of course one man
used all those talents for good and one
use them for evil
so oratory is a tricky thing i mean it's
clear what makes a good oratory but it's
not always used for the best purposes
greg thank you so much for joining us
today where can people learn more about
you and the work that you do
well it's a fun conversation i like
talking about this stuff and if people
are curious about my work uh check out
my website uh i have a website that's
gregorysaldrete.com no spaces so just
gregory saldrete.com
and you'll see what i've done and what
i'm working on
all right greg i will say this as i
perform the hand gesture of wonderment
it is great to talk to you and we'll
talk again soon thank you enjoyed the
conversation
and that'll do it for another episode of
one dream now to learn who our upcoming
guests are and to ask them questions
make sure to keep an eye on our social
media feeds you can find links to all of
them in the description below
we'll be back soon with another great
show be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss it